so moving on from all this planning
going over to after shooting the piece
right now we're two days into it's been
an interesting experience project you
kind of want to make things feel
accidental every once in a while
sometimes things are unexpected I can
talk to animals the only way to keep
doing that is to just start mixing
things up you know don't have people try
and hit marks too specifically don't
keep the camera too steady or tubular
you need something that energy and every
single take and every single shot so I
think that's one of the things we're
starting to find the group on here if
you want to succeed against the super
villain you need a sidekick this is my
sidekick his name is this project is
completely different for us because
unlike a lot of the pieces we are
normally making this one is one instance
the 100 of personalities from YouTube
etc hey how you guys doing yeah dog
special powers hey snapchat me a picture
of yourself as a cat and it makes the
process onset completely different
because while we do have our lines in
our our scripts so to speak for the
piece the biggest thing for us to
recognize as directors is that everyone
has their own audience and their own
style that they're known for and we
honestly don't want to push them too far
outside of that because it's really why
people will be coming to watch this
locations we filmed out have been
awesome so far like right now we are at
trampoline art there's like freerunning
stuff I'm on like a little kid toy for
adults I am a monkey I love trampolines
I love jumping around and it's been
super fun and I don't know what else to
talk about so
so great ideas sent to us on the phones
we shot on the phones snapping on
episodes on the phones just the whole
show is the mobile production it's a
really unique experience for us so
working with all the people on snapper
hero-like shonduras i think i just
doodled my cell phone my hair my makeup
dude so we're breaking ground here the
corridor digital guy is insane yeah if
you wanted to direct the shop Carly this
is weird cut the counter Freddie good
beard of that it's been so much fun
meeting all these guys and getting to
interact with them and see what they're
like in person versus like their online
personas has been really eye-opening and
just a blast cuz we all just like we
mess around it's time to do a shot and
then we're like you guys we're
professional was serious uh-huh
doodles they're everywhere thanks for
watching see you next time
gopher Anna go for Simone I can do
anything I can wiggle my ears superhero
style tip number one always wear masks
y'all going to be